ça m'apporte bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
date du déconfinement progressif le 11
mai prochain divise estimez vous que les
mesures sanitaires sont suffisantes pour
protéger les cheminots non je recueille
sont pas suffisantes mais pas simplement
pour les cheminots ne sont pas
suffisantes aussi pour les usagers
en réalité on était dans l'amateurisme
dans la gestion du confinement et dans
la sortie du des continents on est aussi
dans l'amateurisme n'y a rien qui est
prêt on n'a pas de plan de transport est
en réalité on s'apprête à rouvrir les
écoles et à renvoyer les gens dans les
transports simplement pour répondre à
une logique financière et aux desiderata
du grand patronat
et c'est pas sérieux parce qu'on sait
pas quel masque seront disponibles on
sait pas si les gens qui repartent au
travail seront testés ou pas et on sait
que les gars avec les écoles sont des
foyers de contamination extrêmement
important je rappelle qu'au début de la
crise quand même quand les transports
publics étaient toujours ouverts
les cheminots étaient contaminés huit
fois plus que la moyenne nationale donc
on prend un risque énorme et aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment pas sérieux et on tire le
signal d'alarmé
attention à une reprise de trois pieds
d'eau dans ce conteste dans ce contexte
pardon vous envisagez de ne pas
reprendre le travail le 11 mai prochain
aujourd'hui le message il est clair si
ya pas de protection nécessaires pour
les salariés des transports publics ou
privés ou pour les usagers il y aura pas
de reprise possible
on sait aujourd'hui que le patronat des
transports a fait une lettre à edouard
philippe dire que s'ils avaient des
masques y compris des masques artisanaux
c'était suffisant et on n'aurait pas
besoin de respecter la distinction
sociale
c'est pour nous absolument inacceptable
on voit que le conseil scientifique dit
que le masque ne dispense pas des autres
gestes barrières et comment voulez vous
que dans des trains ou des rames de
métro aux heures de pointe ont pu
espacer les gens si on réfléchit pas à
des plans de transport en amont et
aujourd'hui c'est absolument pas ce qui
fait le gouvernement
simplement il dit il appelle à la
responsabilité individuelle au port du
masque et en disant ça suffit donc c'est
extrêmement dangereux il ya clairement
une mise en danger de la vie d'autrui si
on reprend les transports publics dans
ces conditions là le 11 mais elle a
concrètement quelles solutions vous
proposer pour reprendre le travail dans
des
à conditions plus ou moins protégés vous
savez déjà rien que pour la sncf c'est
quasiment 5 millions de voyageurs par
jour dans des périodes normales donc ça
voudrait dire 5 millions de masques par
jour et ce qu'on demande nous se
démasque partisane au jeu des masques
ffp2 qui sont susceptibles de protéger
dans des environnements qui sont
surchargés je dirais puisqu'on sait que
en période normale déjà aux heures de
pointe
les transports publics sont déjà
surchargés donc nous on demande c'est
d'avoir un plan de transport c'est à
dire que toutes les entreprises qui vont
reprendre le travail
elles disent où c'est que leurs salariés
réside à quelle heure il faut qu'ils
embauchent comme ça on peut organiser en
amont le transfert de ces personnes-là
est décalé dans le temps
bien évidemment c'est complexe ça
nécessite des moyens humains mais c'est
réalisable
on l'a fait un peu plus tôt dans la
crise avec le personnel hospitalier à
plus petite échelle mais il faut pouvoir
le reproduire et c'est le rôle de l'état
est vraiment je le redis c'est
totalement irresponsable de dire que le
11 mai avec un masque on pourra prendre
les transports comme si de rien n'était
c'est vraiment pas sérieux
il ya les conditions ne seront peut-être
pas prêt pour le 11 mai pour reprendre
un trafic régulier à la sncf ou la ratp
il faudrait décaler cette date à votre
avis je crois qu'il faut regarder un peu
comment va évoluer
l'épidémie déjà il faut appeler toutes
les entreprises qui font du télétravail
qu'elle puisse continuer et que les gens
puissent rester chez eux sans que la
priorité aujourd'hui c'est pas la
reprise de l'économie c'est quand même
la santé des citoyens de ce pays et on
ne comprend pas bien pourquoi cette date
du 11 mai elle est venue comme ça de la
part d' emmanuel macron sans consulter
personne sans associer qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs le conseil scientifique est
plutôt circonspect d'après ce que je
sais sur ces dates là donc qu'il faut
regarder tout ça avec tranquillité et
surtout pas agir dans la précipitation
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des signaux
qui s'anime un peu partout où on peut
avoir une deuxième vague qui est celle
là sera encore plus mortelle donc je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ouvrir comme ça les
transports publics simplement pour
relancer l'économie c'est pas sérieux ça
encore une fois ça prouve que ce
gouvernement il a une simplement une
lecture financière de la crise qu'il
veut absolument répondre aux intérêts de
quelques années y compris en mettant en
danger la santé de
une voire deux millions de personnes
donc c'est extrêmement grave ce qui se
passe et je crois que il faut vraiment
que toutes les conditions à minima si on
veut reprendre les transports il faut
des masques ffp2 pour tous les gens il
faut la distanciation sociale il faut
que les salariés qui reprennent le
travail soient testées pour savoir s'ils
ont le virus ou pas pour pouvoir les
isolés ne pas créer des nouvelles vagues
de contagion ça m'apporte merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes responsable du
collectif cheminots au pcf